[Música]
hola bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en esta
oportunidad está con nosotros el doctor
oscar franco director del instituto de
medicina social y preventiva de la
ciudad de berna en suiza y vamos a
hablar con él sobre la relación que
tiene la vacunación contra el kobe 19 el
ciclo menstrual y la fertilidad femenina
doctor como siempre un gusto saludarlo y
comienzo por preguntar la medida que
está avanzando la vacunación en el mundo
han sido reportados en varios lugares
cambios en los ciclos menstruales de las
mujeres que ya han recibido vacunas de
qué tipo de cambios estamos hablando y
qué magnitud tiene este fenómeno
así es estamos viendo cambios que se
están reportando cada vez más en todo el
mundo también se ha reportado a mí
varias personas que conozco y son
cambios que pueden ocurrir generalmente
la edad fértil de las mujeres aunque se
han reportado sangrados también en
mujeres que ya estaban en menopausia y
los cambios que se reportan eso que el
periodo no llega y se tarda en llegar o
que se hace irregular o que cuando llega
al sangrado es abundante con coágulos y
que da cólicos y dolor mayor que el que
antes o personas también reportan
sangrados que son más escasos entonces
por ahora lo que estamos viendo son
cambios que están ocurriendo en muchas
mujeres pero que no se están
cuantificando los de manera suficiente
doctor hay muchos reportes entonces
quiero saber si ya hay estudios que
estén avanzando para determinar cuáles
son las causas en las causas de lo que
podría estar ocurriendo
los estudios están empezando para mirar
si realmente hay una causa en las
vacunas que puedan generar este cambio
sin embargo en estos días se reportó
buenos en el reino unido- que unas 4.000
mujeres de millones que se han vacunado
había reportado cambios en el ciclo
menstrual sin embargo es posible que ese
número sea simplemente una muestra
pequeña porque muchas mujeres que han
reportado que han tenido este problema
no lo han reportado las autoridades lo
que estamos viendo es que tiende a
afectar más a las mujeres entre los 30 y
los 45 años y vamos a ver en los
próximos estudios cuando salgan si hay
una causalidad entre las vacunas ya que
personas específicamente están afectando
más doctor estos problemas estarían
relacionados con alguna vacuna en
particular están relacionados con todas
las vacunas que están disponibles en el
mercado para hacer frente al cómic 19
que saben hasta ahora
hasta ahora lo que estamos viendo del
reino unido- de esas 4000 personas que
reportaban estos cambios ésta había sido
vacunadas con astrazéneca o con files
sería algunas con modernas porque
modernas apenas está empezando en el
reino unido lo que tenemos que entender
es que el ciclo menstrual es un periodo
en el que el revestimiento interno del
útero que se llama endometrio empieza a
crecer para poder alojar un óvulo cuando
esté fecundado
cuando es fertilizado entonces si esto
no ocurre al final del ciclo esa capa
del endometrio se sabe lo que es la
menstruación este proceso está
coordinado por las hormonas por procesos
inflamatorios y por el sistema inmune
entonces yo creo que es más el efecto
que tienen las vacunas en el sistema
inmune no solamente de manera
generalizada sino también localizada en
el útero y no creo que sea
específicamente de ninguna vacuna pero
eso se tiene que evaluar por supuesto
doctor eso en cuanto al ciclo menstrual
pero las vacunas podrían tener algún
tipo de impacto en la fertilidad de las
mujeres a corto mediano o largo plazo
después de ser vacunadas
la probabilidad es casi inexistente lo
más seguro es que esto sea un impacto
que sea temporal por eso por ese cambio
en el sistema inmune que inducen las
vacunas durante un mes o dos meses no
sería la primera vacuna en la que se ha
reportado cambios en el ciclo menstrual
también se ha reportado con la vacuna de
la gripe con la vacuna del papiloma y se
ha visto que estos cambios pues no son
muy duraderos simplemente son temporales
y recientemente vimos reportes de
estudios de espermatozoides en hombres
antes y después de ser vacunados y no
tenían cambios no se veían afectados
entonces yo creo que la probabilidad de
que afecte la fertilidad es inexistente
o mínima doctor para el cierre entonces
qué pueden hacer las mujeres que están
experimentando cambios en sus ciclos
después de haber sido vacunadas qué
medidas deben tomar
en primer lugar no preocuparse porque
esto es algo que se puede esperar que
puede ocurrir con las vacunas en segundo
lugar es reportarlo es importante que lo
reportan para saber si está ocurriendo y
en qué tamaño está ocurriendo en tercer
lugar a las autoridades que hablen con
las mujeres cuando se están poniendo las
vacunas que esto puede ocurrir para
evitar que haya ansiedad o que haya
temor y en cuarto lugar si las mujeres
tienen la cita para la vacuna si tienen
el periodo no teman ir a vacunarse
gracias doctor por esta consulta de
ustedes gracias por la sintonía sigan
con nosotros
[Música]